MEMBERS OF THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE ARE PREPARING FOR
TOMORROW'S PRIMETIME HEARING.
THE HEARING IS EXPECTED TO COVER
THE ACTIONS OR LACK THEREOF OF
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP DURING
THE THREE-PLUS HOURS THAT
RIOTERS WERE STORMING THE
CAPITOL AND THE PRESIDENT'S
ACTIVITIES WERE UNKNOWN.
BUT AS COMMITTEE MEMBERS TRY TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THE PAST
ATTEMPT TO TEAL THE ELECTION,
OUR DEMOCRACY REMAINS UNDER
ATTACK BY THE SAME FORCES.
LET'S START IN WISCONSIN.
CNN AFFILIATE WISM REPORTS THAT
DONALD TRUMP CALLED THE TOP
LAWMAKER IN THE WISCONSIN STATE
ASSEMBLY, REPUBLICAN ROBIN VOSS,
AND ASKED HIM TO OVERTURN THE
2020 ELECTION RESULTS.
WHEN DID THAT CALL HAPPEN?
THAT CALL HAPPENED LAST WEEK.
LAST WEEK.
DONALD TRUMP IS STILL TRYING TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION RESULTS
FROM ALMOST TWO YEARS AGO.
LISTEN TO HOW VOSS DESCRIBES THE
CALL.
>> HE MAKES HIS CASE, WHICH I
RESPECT.
HE WOULD LIKE US TO DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT IN WISCONSIN.
I EXPLAINED IT'S NOT ALLOWED
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION.
>> TRUMP THEN WENT ON SOCIAL
MEDIA, OF COURSE, AND ATTACKED
HIM.
LET'S GO TO ARIZONA NOW.
IN ARIZONA LATE LAST NIGHT, THE
STATE'S REPUBLICAN PARTY
CENSURED ITS REPUBLICAN HOUSE
SPEAKER, RUSTY BOWERS, BECAUSE
RUSTY BOWERS TESTIFIED
FACTUALLY, BEFORE THE JANUARY
6th COMMITTEE LAST MONTH AND
SAID THAT HE TOLD TRUMP HE WOULD
NOT PARTICIPATE IN TRUMP'S FAKE
ELECTORS SCHEME.
>> I SAID WHAT WOULD YOU HAVE ME
DO?
HE SAID, JUST DO IT AND LET THE
COURTS SORT IT OUT.
YOU'RE ASKING ME TO DO SOMETHING
THAT IS COUNTER TO MY OATH, WHEN
I SWORE TO THE CONSTITUTION TO
UPHOLD IT, I WILL NOT BREAK MY
OATH.
>> THE CHAIR OF THE ARIZONA
STATE REPUBLICAN COMMITTEE,
KELLI WARD, TWEETED ABOUT
BOWERS, SAYING, QUOTE, HE IS NO
LONGER A REPUBLICAN IN GOOD
STANDING, AND WE CALL ON
REPUBLICANS TO REPLACE HIM AT
THE BALLOT BOX, UNQUOTE.
WARD, WE SHOULD NOTE, ALSO
SERVED AS A FAKE ELECTOR IN
ARIZONA FOR DONALD TRUMP.
SHE AND HER HUSBAND HAVE BOTH
BEEN SUBPOENAED IN THE FEDERAL
PROBE INTO THE FRAUDULENT
ELECTOR SCHEME.
THOUGH THE WARDS' ATTORNEY SAY
THEIR ACTIONS ARE PROTECT EED B
THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
LET'S HOP OVER TO MARYLAND WHERE
LAST NIGHT, CNN PROJECTED DAN
COX WOULD BE THE WINNER OF THE
REPUBLICAN PRIMARY IN THE
STATE'S GOVERNOR'S RACE.
COX WAS, AND REMAINS, A BIG
DISSEMINATOR OF TRUMP'S ELECTION
LIES.
HE TWEETED ON JANUARY 6th, WHILE
RIOTERS WERE ACTIVELY BREACHING
THE CAPITOL PERIMETER, QUOTE,
PENCE IS A TRAITOR.
THAT'S THE REPUBLICAN
GUBERNATORIAL NOMINEE IN
MARYLAND.
EXTREMIST IDEOLOGIES ABOUND
TODAY.
AUDIO CIRCULATED FROM A FORMER
TRUMP WHITE HOUSE AIDE WHO
RANTED ABOUT HIS MEETING WITH
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE
YESTERDAY, THE AIDE, GARRETT
ZIEGLER, WENT ON A LIVE STREAM
SUGGESTING THAT THE JANUARY 6th
INVESTIGATION IS AN ATTEMPT TO
GO AFTER WHITE CHRISTIANS.
>> THEY'RE BOL SHU CHICS SO THEY
PROBABLY DO HATE THE AMERICANS
AND MOST WHITE PEOPLE IN
GENERAL.
THIS IS AN ANTI-WHITE CAMPAIGN.
IF YOU CAN'T SEE THAT, YOUR EYES
ARE FREAKING CLOSED.
AND SO THEY SEE ME AS A YOUNG
CHRISTIAN WHO THEY CAN TRY TO
BASICALLY SCARE.
RIGHT?
>> A BOL SHUIVIST ANTI-WHITE
CAMPAIGN GOING AGAINST
CHRISTIANS.
MASK OFF.
NOW, IT MIGHT BE TEMPTING TO
COMPARE DONALD TRUMP TO THE
JAPANESE SERGEANT DISCOVERED
HIDING IN THE JUNGLES OF GUAM IN
1972, 27 YEARS AFTER WORLD WAR
II HAD ENDED, MISTAKENLY OF THE
BELIEF THAT WORLD WAR II WAS
STILL GOING ON, THAT THE
JAPANESE HAD NOT LOST, BUT HE
WAS JUST ONE MAN.
DONALD TRUMP HAS AN ARMY OF
SIMILARLY DELUDED AND ILL
INFORMED ZEALOTS, AND THEY
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR THAT
CORRUPT CAUSE.
LAWMAKERS, PARTY SHARES, FORMER
WHITE HOUSE AIDES, STILL
SPREADING TRUMP'S LIES.
AND THEY AREN'T EVEN JUST SAYING
IT.
MANY OF THEM ARE CAMPAIGNING ON
IT AND WINNING REPUBLICAN
PRIMARIES ON IT.
EVEN AS THEY FIGHT TO UNDO THE
COUNTRY'S ELECTION LAWS TODAY.
RIGHT NOW.
THE CLEAR AND PRESENT THREAT TO
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY CONTINUES.